wie ist das denn eigentlich im moment so
es ist sind corinna zeiten und wenn man
genau hinschaut
man hat das gefühl umarmungen gibt es in
der serie im moment gerade nicht so wie
sie lebt sie es dann in dieser blase
oder wir sind dort die
sicherheitsvorkehrung also es ist so
dass wir wirklich mit strengsten
sicherheitsmaßnahmen drehen immer im
studio auch nicht nur indirekt da wo wir
drehen sondern auch in den gebäuden
anderthalb meter abstand mass pflicht
man muss also immer die maske tragen und
nur kurz vorm dreh blut abgenommen und
also viel schminken uns jetzt wieder
selbst das war vorher nicht mehr machen
muss aber jetzt müssen wir da machen und
er leider gottes berührungen sex küsse
und so weiter läuft alles über hauben
und überblicke ist nicht mehr machbar
[Musik]